how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the mcu and today
we have some
extremely exciting news in regards to
marvel studios and
phase four and specifically some
incredibly good news about the falcon
and the winter soldier series
the loki series and the hawkeye series
which is really great because
unfortunately due to covet 19 marvel
studios and the movie industry in
general took
a massive hit and marvel studios for the
safety of everybody that works for them
had to shut down the production
of all of their current projects so
unfortunately any leaked photos from the
sets
videos from the sets any possible chance
of teaser trailers coming sooner than
later all got shut down for a little bit
but the great news is that marvel
studios is starting back up again and
production
is resuming for their current projects
and i'm going to break down
the latest report in this video so if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on all the latest
mcu content and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win a
gambit
funko pop all you got to do is subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below
so as i mentioned today we received the
awesome
epic news that marvel studios is
resuming production on
three projects and those three projects
are the falcon
in the winter soldier series the hawkeye
series and the loki series
now the falcon in the winter soldier
series was pretty much almost complete
they have a little bit more shooting to
do but then they'll be done and wrapping
up and go into the editing process which
means not only could we expect a teaser
trailer soon but we can expect an
official full-length trailer pretty soon
and that also means the falcon and the
winter soldier could still be released
this year many fans were worried that
due to cover 19
everything was going to be pushed back
and we weren't going to get any marvel
content this year
everybody was fearful about falcon in
the winter soldier black widow and one
division being pushed back to 2021 but
since marvel studios is back in action
and working on these projects and going
to complete them soon there's hope that
they will release in 2020 because falcon
in the winter soldier is on disney plus
and in fact it seems like marvel studios
is ahead of schedule from when they plan
to come back and resume production and
this comes from charles murphy
today on murphy's multiverse.com they
posted that the crew
is indeed returning to work on the
productions of these projects and he
said
cruz 4 the falcon and the winter soldier
loki
and hawkeye moved back into town and got
the ball rolling again on the three
upcoming marvel studios disney plus
streaming series and these crews
returned back to atlanta where they were
filming before and they also posted that
the studio
said back in early july that they had
hoped to resume filmings on these
projects by august
17th and here's marvel studios plans to
resume production on the falcon in the
winter soldier
and finish it as stated on murphy's
multiverse.com
it says the plan is for things to
restart in atlanta
on august 17th both loki and falcon
would get going again
at pinewood then we slash i have known
that
falcon had more to do in atlanta at a
set they already used previously
i could tell you what slash who they
want to film there but
that won't work out well for me so i'll
just say it'll be a very cool
cameo assuming they go with the original
plan then
for falcon it sounds like off to prague
for 9 days
if everything were to go according to
plan they'd very likely be able to get
the show on disney plus before the end
of 2020
so the crew is there already back in
atlanta and it's august
7th looks like everything will
definitely be ready by august 17th
which means we're going to be getting a
lot more content very soon
including some possible leaked photos
and videos from the set
of the falcon and the winter soldier and
possibly figure out who that mysterious
cameo is it's been speculated
and rumored that the falcon and the
winter soldier could set up
wolverine so perhaps this could be a
logan
teaser but that is just pure speculation
at this point
but the good news is that the falcon and
the winter soldier loki and the hawkeye
series are starting
back up again phase 4 is continuing so
let me know what you think about this
super exciting
news and which marvel series on disney
plus are you looking forward to
the most let me know what you think in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe to stay up
to date on all the latest
mcu news for live updates you can always
follow me on twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof